en su tercera visita a Venezuela el
fiscal de la Corte Penal Internacional
karincan se reunió con autoridades del
poder ejecutivo del poder judicial a fin
de avanzar en las investigaciones para
determinar si en Venezuela se cometieron
crímenes de lesa humanidad bajo la
administración de Nicolás maduro una
visita que no fue anunciada con
antelación y que en principio se manejó
con total hermetismo la fiscalía también
investiga si los tribunales en Venezuela
imparten justicia en los casos de
violaciones a derechos humanos que se
han denunciado recordemos que hace un
mes aproximadamente la fiscalía recibió
cerca de ocho mil novecientos
testimonios de personas que se
consideran Víctimas de abuso por parte
del Estado venezolano y aproximadamente
en marzo del año pasado el fiscal había
advertido que se abriría una oficina en
Venezuela para brindar asistencia
técnica a las autoridades en horas de la
noche el fiscal de la Corte Penal
Internacional también acudió al palacio
de Miraflores Allí se reunió con el
presidente Nicolás maduro y con la
primera dama Silvia flores al momento no
ha habido declaraciones a los medios de
comunicación y se desconoce si karinkan
se va a reunir con representantes de
organizaciones no gubernamentales y
asociaciones de víctimas algunas de
ellas se han pronunciado a través de
redes sociales Como por ejemplo provea
que han dicho que en Venezuela se
necesitan investigaciones genuinas y no
simulaciones de justicia